[Music]
where are you hang in there all right
let's go
rooster is the son of goose who was
maverick swing man in the first top gun
i got you back
there's been some complicated history
between brewster and maverick my dad
believed in you i'm not gonna make the
same mistake he's just an extremely
intelligent and talented pilot jeez
rooster not that fast but he has a lot
to learn forget the book trust your
instincts
so rooster learns to test his own limits
show me what you're made of
[Music]
everyone here is the best there is who
the hell are they going to get to teach
us phoenix is definitely a tough cookie
she doesn't underestimate anyone and
she's very loyal you're my new
backseater he's not cut out for this
mission don't take the bait bob
she's probably the leader of the group
her leadership qualities come through
quite a bit
what do you want to do we're close stay
on target
[Music]
what have we here that's a kill coyote
you're good
coyote is very very competitive he
always feels that he has to prove
himself try to stay with me this guy
needs an ego check he's gonna see a
coyote
because he can command the team his
leadership presence it makes him one of
the best pilots we're out of time i'm
increasing speed
what do they call you
bob no your call sign
bob literally
bob is a weapon systems officer he's the
back seater we are two seconds behind
increased to 489. he's dropping the
bombs being the second pair of eyes for
the pilot we ready on that laser bob
copy laser is a good
[Music]
greetings fanboy today's exercise is dog
fighting whenever we get shut down have
to do 200 push-ups they don't call it an
exercise for nothing sir
fanboy is a weapon system operator he's
a backseater in the air he's helping a
pilot with everything in the cockpit
i got this the mission he's training for
seems almost impossible guys we're
flying behind right maverick pushes
pilots to think outside the box push
beyond your lemons
[Music]
who's gonna be team leader and which one
he all has what it takes to follow me
let's go let's see what you got
hangman's coming hangman he doesn't fly
well with the team sort of lives on the
edge you put your team in danger i
couldn't keep up he knows he's the best
and he's not here to make friends
you with me right behind you crispy
right now payback is very confident damn
right let's say we put some skin in the
game and then as maverick starts to test
the class you kind of see that fall
apart
but he sooner realizes there couldn't be
a better instructor than maverick i'm
going to train you to take your aircraft
to the breaking point
good morning aviators this is your
captain speaking let's get to work
in this movie maverick is still a hot
shot he's still doing what he wants to
do who'd you piss off this time another
admiral
he's the ultimate aviator and he craves
adrenaline and craves the unknown all
right gentlemen fights on
nice he takes risks but he really does
have everyone's best interests at heart
he is an iconic character and he
continues to test his own limits
the end is inevitable maverick the kind
is headed for extinction
sir
but not today come on
having any fun yet
what do we have here yeah here i thought
we were special fellas this here's
bagman hang man whatever what the hell
kind of mission is this
[Music]
everyone here is the best there is who
the hell are they gonna get to teach us
captain pete maverick mitchell
let me be perfectly blunt
you are not my first choice you were
here at the request of admiral kazansky
aka iceman he seems to think that you
have something left to offer the navy
what that is i can't imagine
you all due respect sir i'm not a
teacher
i just want to manage expectations
good morning aviators
this is your captain speaking
then we're off
here
in three
two
one
we're going into combat on a level no
living pilot's ever seen
not even him
you think up there you're dead believe
me
my dad believed in you
i'm not gonna make the same mistake
[Music]
someone's not coming back from this
those are your pilots
anything happens to them
you'll never forgive yourself
no turning back now come on
[Music]
[Music]
we are cleared into the area verified
cameras are on all right here we go
three two one
here
all right that was awesome
i wasn't ready to make a sequel until we
had a special story worthy of a sequel
and until technology evolved so we could
delve deeper into the experience of a
fighter
the first movie became something that
changed a generation
so this is exciting to come back and get
those jets again
we worked with the navy and the top gun
school to formulate how to shoot it
practically because if we're going to do
it we're going to fly in the f-18s
the aviation sequences had to be real
so our actors went through three months
of ruling training
the navy says if you eject you have to
be able to survive in the water so we
had to go through that challenging
underwater program
it's intense you're flipped inverted and
you're having to try and get out
from there tom designed this
all-encompassing aviation training for
all the actors
i started mounting a single engine
airplane to build up their spatial
awareness inside the aircraft
next we took them to the l-39 and they
went and flew aerobatics to feel what
it's like in a jet
speed
from there they'd graduate to the f-18
super hornet and actually launching off
an aircraft carrier
the actors also had to learn how to run
the cameras because when they're up in
the jet they have to direct themselves
essentially okay
i had to really teach them
cinematography and the lighting so that
they understood what's going to look
good on camera angle is great
everybody thought it would be impossible
for actors to really be in the jets
but that's the gift that tom gave us
that by the time we got up there
we could handle it
definitely the most amazing thing i've
ever done all the training 100 prepared
i'm very proud of what we all accomplish
each one of them are extraordinary
it still blows my mind that we've done
this
there's nothing like it
in top gun maverick you're going to see
real actors in the cockpit
and the full capability of the airplane
when you're watching the movie
when you get up there you have a new
respect for fighter pilots
there's nothing like it
that's a kill
when i first found out that we had to be
in jets
i was excited
[Music]
i didn't expect anything less because
it's tom cruise he does all of his
stunts so i expected us to have to do it
too
but when it became real like oh
i don't want to do this anymore
oh okay one of my favorite analogies
that some of the top gun pilots have
it's like being strapped on to a dragon
i told everyone if you take this role
part of it is being in that f-18 i don't
know how to do it any other way
being in an f-18 is
unreal there's gonna be a lot of stuff
that people see and go no way they
really did that
and we really did that
tom said i need this to happen at 30
feet above the ground
he was doing 480 knots basically a 500
mile an hour race car
i've been doing this in these airplanes
for a really long time and i watch that
and i go wow that's fantastic
i wanted to celebrate the fighter pilot
watching them explore what we do
it's breathtaking
there's nothing like it
the navy and the top gun team oh they're
amazing
[Music]
[Music]
you